the EPA comes into your life and tells
you no you're not going to build there
because we say so not with any facts it
is their opinion that is a very tough
thing to swallow when you're a taxpayer
in this country
the EPA wanted to make a point and say
we have the authority in this country to
tell you where you can and cannot build
until the Supreme Court took up the
Sacketts case every Federal Court of
Appeals in this country had ruled
against the position that the Sacketts
were articulated
[Music]
mike and chantell sackett dreamed of
building a beautiful home in Priest Lake
Idaho when I was in high school I was up
there camping and fell in love with
Priest Lake I remember coming home told
my mom and dad that I was gonna move to
Priest Lake and they just said oh no
you're not and I said yeah yeah I am I
will figure it out in the summertime oh
there's no other place you'd want to be
it is so peaceful and calm Christine in
2008 the Sacketts purchased a modest
plot of land in a subdivision bordering
Priest Lake and prepared to build a home
this was our this was where we were
going to live for the rest of our life
as far as we were concerned this was
going to be our our home home the second
zone an excavating business and are
accustomed to navigating the building
permit process which is why they were
all the more shocked when officials from
the EPA and the Army Corps of Engineers
showed up just three days after they'd
begun to clear the lot and fill in the
foundation with gravel the gentleman
that was there that was working he said
they walked on to the property and said
you need to stop work immediately and he
said why they said because we think
you're filling in wetland Chantal and
her office manager tried to reason with
the EPA over the phone but got nowhere
well do you have anything in writing and
they said no well do you have like a
stop-work order or anything and they
said no do you have any proof that shows
that that lot is in a in a wetlands no
we don't need any we think you're
working in a wetland the official told
the Sacketts that their property was
listed in the National wetlands
inventory and was therefore under the
jurisdiction of the EPA except there was
a one problem when we pulled up the
coordinates on that piece of property
where our lot was there was no wetland
there when I called her and told her
that she goes well it's not always
correct it's a tool we use and I said
okay so you're gonna stop me from
working on our property that we paid for
because of a national wetland inventory
that isn't always correct how does that
work without further explanation
the EPA issued the Sacketts a compliance
order claiming that they were building
on wetland
and therefore violating the Clean Water
Act the Clean Water Act passed in 1972
in order to restore and maintain the
chemical physical and biological
integrity of the nation's waters
violation of this act results in fines
up to thirty seven thousand five hundred
dollars a day the Sacketts hired
scientists to inspect their landlocked
property and they couldn't find any
evidence of wetlands the EPA wasn't
offering any evidence either in the
meantime the fines were racking up you
go to bed with that on your mind every
night it's been painful personally it's
been painful on our business and we've
had employees leave because there's
employees that are looking at us like
well these guys you know if they get
this fine they're done it's a horrible
thing to have to think about it every
day
if the Sacketts gave in to the EPA they
would be required to restore the land to
its natural state and actually plant
non-native plants that are found in
wetlands thus transforming their
previously dry property into protected
wetlands you can't win because they back
you in and when you do what they tell
you to do you just made your property a
wetland facing no other viable option
the Sacketts decided to fight the EPA's
compliance order in court unfortunately
for them this also was not an option we
will not allow you to sue the EPA is
what they said twice the EPA took the
position that because they were not
actually enforcing the penalties yet
that the compliance order amounted to
nothing more than a warning and could
therefore not be challenged in court
remarkably the district court and the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals agreed
with the EPA the government cannot take
from you your life your liberty or your
property without first giving you as the
Constitution calls a due process of law
Damien Schiff is an attorney at the
Pacific Legal Foundation which took up
the Sacketts case against the EPA we
invited officials from the EPA and the
Department of Justice to participate in
this video as well but they declined the
sac is hired wetlands experts soil
scientists hydrologists and their
conclusion is that there are not
wetlands on this
property EPA has told them you cannot
use your property you must pay a fine
your property will become a de facto
wetlands preserve for the indefinite
future and we're going to take your
property away from you effectively
without giving you any notice without
giving you any hearing without giving
you any opportunity to present contrary
evidence millions of dollars in
potential fines accumulated over the
years as the courts denied the Sacketts
the right to even have their challenge
to the compliance order heard Damien
says you know the only place we can go
and I said I don't that's not easy I
said yeah but what choice do we have
he said it's like winning the lotto yeah
I get to the Supreme Court but the
Sacketts won that lottery and had their
case heard by the Supreme Court in
January of 2012 the EPA proceeded to
argue that the Sacketts had no right to
challenge a compliance order because the
Clean Water Act was intended to preclude
pre-enforcement judicial review of the
order the problem is the only way the
Sacketts could ever get judicial review
that way is by ignoring the compliance
order and racking up potentially
millions of dollars in fines and even
then not having certainty that EPA will
bring a lawsuit EPA might still just sit
on its hands and let the possible fines
pile up EPA also says its ability to
protect the environment would be
substantially undermined if compliance
order recipients could immediately Hale
the agency into court and that
compliance orders obviate the need for
judicial intervention by inducing
compliance individuals private property
rights and other constitutionally
protected liberties are being violated
every day by this agency and what does
the agency say agency says it doesn't
want to go into court it shouldn't have
to go into court to defend these very
actions that are violating the rights of
the people the hood spa the arrogance is
frankly almost unimaginable for now the
seconds must wait for the Supreme
Court's ruling but they are cautiously
optimistic we had a good day in court we
were both surprised with
some of the questions that came from the
justices they were questions that we
would have asked without the tax payers
in this country they don't exist so why
do they get to come into people's lives
and turn them upside down that's a darn
good question that that needs to be
answered
[Music]